geller gauvin a consacré cette année 10%
de ses terres au sorgho l'avantagent de
cette céréale est évident elle a besoin
de moins d'eau pour se développer mais
comme toutes les autres il lui faut
quand même un minimum de pluie les
feuilles sont stressés à se protègent du
soleil le sorgho souffre après on espère
de l'eau le plus rapidement possible
mais là le rendement va être impactée
pratiquement sur la moitié quoi le
sorgho et la cinquième céréales
produites au monde essentiellement en
afrique il est très loin derrière le blé
le riz et le maïs il y a deux étaient en
2020 le sorgho représenté 9 mille
hectares de terres cultivées sur les 400
milles d'indre et loire ce qui
représente entre 3 et 4% le grand
avantage du sorgho sait qu'il a besoin
de deux fois moins d'eau que le maïs à
30 kilomètres de là plus à l'ouest
fabien labrunie a été un pionnier il ya
15 ans en touraine cette année il a semé
11 hectares de sorgho sur les 160 de son
exploitation je me suis mis au savon
avant tout pour diversifier la seulement
on a besoin d'avoir plusieurs cultures
pour utiliser le moins de produits
chimiques possibles notamment et le
sorgho c'est une très bonne plante
puisque c'est une des rares plantes
qu'on peut semer au mois de mai pour la
récolte au mois d'octobre ce qui est un
cycle très décalé par rapport aux autres
cultures
le sorgho peut être utilisé en farine en
grains ou pour le fourrage mais son
grand défaut est son manque de rendement
40 quintaux à l'hectare en moyenne soit
deux fois moins que le maïs aujourd'hui
le maïs c'est une nourriture de base de
l'alimentation animale et même de
l'alimentation humaine parce que il est
capable de produire une quantité très
importante de nourriture à l'hectare par
contre dans des terres où on a bien du
mal à stocker l'eau l'hiver dans les
terres où on ne peut pas irriguées bien
entendu le cerveau il a toute sa place
et il vient en complément du maïs le
sorgho n'est donc pas une solution à
part entière mais un complément une
mauvaise nouvelle alors qu'il supporte
bien plus que les autres les fortes
chaleurs